[Musique]
tous les partis se réclament du vote des
jeunes
venance un appel aux jeunes du québec on
veut accueillir cette année les milenio
on a besoin d'avoir plus de jeunes un
des thèmes importants de la campagne ce
thème puis associé au changement donc
parler de la jeunesse et parler de
renouveau et cette année des chercheurs
ont calculé que les jeunes électeurs ont
le même poids démographique que les
générations qui les ont précédés
oui je vais voter aux prochaines
élections oui j'ai pas voté mais
faudrait que je m'informe je connais pas
encore qui se présente on la première
fois dans les 50 dernières années on a
trois groupes générationnel qui se
partagent le poids de l'électorat selon
les travaux du professeur françois
gélineau la génération née avant 1960
âgé aujourd'hui de plus de 58 ans la
génération x âgés de 39 à 58 ans et la
génération y
âgés de 18 à 38 ans vont représenter
chacune le tiers de l'électorat le 1er
octobre mais avoir le même poids
démographique ne signifie pas avoir le
même poids politique
d'abord les jeunes d'aujourd'hui votre
moins que leurs prédécesseurs
lorsqu'il avait 18 ans 65 % des
baby-boomers voté aujourd'hui seulement
51 % des jeunes de 18 ans vote
je me dis j'irai pas amants voter parce
que je suis passé avec j'ai pas un choix
éclairé affaires faut être franc j'ai
jamais voté de ma vie non seulement les
jeunes votent moins mais leur
participation varie d'une élection à
l'autre ce qui rend leur comportement
imprévisible parfois que je vais me
renseigner
d'abord
si les jeunes se sentent interpellés par
les enjeux ils vont sortir et ils vont
voter s'ils sont moins interpellé par
les enjeux qui sont débattues où les
enjeux de la campagne électorale ils ont
tendance à moins d'un an suite
lorsqu'ils votent les jeunes sont
politiquement dispersés dans les années
70 on estime que les deux tiers des
jeunes francophones appuyait le parti
québécois est jeune avec instructions
qu'on aime chez mathieu pour décider de
ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui le pq a perdu
son ascendant et les jeunes sont divisés
au niveau de l'environnement vont de la
paix dans le monde
au niveau de la santé je crois qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est pas une jeunesse mais
c'est des jeunesses avec des priorités
différentes
dans un sondage post électorale réalisée
en 2014 par crop spécifiquement auprès
des jeunes
les quatre principaux partis avaient
recueilli chacun entre 20 et 27 pour
cent d'appuis chez les francophones
ça reflète un peu là où se trouve
l'électorat québécois depuis quelques
élections on le voit dans la composition
de l'assemblée nationale avec quatre
partis représentés bref les jeunes sont
proportionnellement plus nombreux mais
pour que ce poids démographique se
traduise réelle influence politique
encore faudrait-il qu'ils votent et
qu'ils expriment des préférences commune
à partir du moment où les jeunes de
votre - et où iodé ddd des divisions au
sein du groupe on peut pas parler d'un
mouvement uniforme
la jeunesse québécoise impôts
monolithique les diversifiés et ça sur
le plan de la démocratie dans des
échanges des débats intéressants au sein
même les jeunes sur différents jeux